hello again it's good to have you back
and yes we really do mean you we're
aware that you watch a lot of these
videos drinking in all that classified
information about some of the scp
foundation's most top secret anomalies
you probably think you're pretty slick
don't you as if nobody could see you
peering in and even if they could they
wouldn't remember it soon after yes
you're a very clever anomaly we wouldn't
even think of arguing against that
that's why this video is about you scp
3393 don't be alarmed we're on the same
page here we know that you access these
files particularly the files regarding
yourself and your own activities we know
that you're on the shy side and we
definitely appreciate that unlike our
other shy guy you don't brutally murder
everyone who witnesses you your greatest
crime is accessing and even tampering
with scp foundation files without
permission but seeing as the foundation
is cold not cruel we can think we can
forgive that little indiscretion of
yours for the greater good all we ask
for is your attention and a few minutes
of your time you're a vain creature who
or whatever you are so we know you
wouldn't even resist the opportunity to
hear what we have to say about you
and for the record you are one of the
few people who are actually witnessing
this video in the way you're witnessing
it right now it's for your eyes only so
to speak
scp-3393 this video its description and
even the coding of its comments section
is filled with state-of-the-art memetic
agents cooked up by our best and
brightest to everyone except you the
researcher heading your case the head of
the anti-mimetics division and a single
member of the o5 council this is just
your average run-of-the-mill video this
is a private conversation between you
and the foundation
scp-3393 we hope you don't mind the
designation it's not like we know your
real name but we can make some rather
educated guesses we actually know very
little about you on the whole a fact we
hope to change in the future much like
several other anomalies we have files on
such as
scp-055 the self-keeping secret and
scp-2256 the very tall things
information recorded about you isn't
exactly sustainable it becomes forgotten
or unreadable shortly after it's noted
down it's a clever anomalous ability and
one we've only been able to counteract
with the application of powerful
amnestic drugs but clearly that isn't
the only thing you have going for you
how do you think you've been able to
access all of these videos filled with
classified information about anomalies
groups of interest and even the inner
workings of the foundation itself
through methods currently unknown to us
you've been able to somehow give your
account level 4 clearance giving you
free rein over almost every file
available as much as it shames us to
admit it we haven't been able to remove
this unpermitted clearance from your
account or even located for that matter
like we've said before you're a very
clever anomaly we respect that about you
even though you've been using this
apparently crafty sapiens to
inconvenience us our best guess is that
you owe much of your success to powerful
anti-memetic properties inherent to your
anomalous being but if we're off the
mark on that do feel free to enlighten
us speaking of guesses let's get back to
what we think we know about you after
all that's why you're really here isn't
it no point being bashful scp-3393
you may be good at hiding yourself but
your intentions are plain as day you
don't need to be a senior researcher
here to intuit that much about you the
following are all facts we believe we
know about you with 90
confidence you'll have to let us know
how close we were in the end assumption
number one you are a corporeal entity
that's right you probably wanted us to
assume that you were some kind of
digital ghost didn't you some mysterious
ethereal thought form existing only in
the realm of cyberspace while you sneak
around site-31 making mischief we're
afraid that the ghost has been given up
so to speak as clever as you are it
isn't quite as clever as you believe
yourself to be you've gotten sloppy at
times and in these moments you've given
us a wealth of evidence don't you think
the foundation researchers and guards
people trained to notice even the most
minute anomalous interference wouldn't
notice doors opening and closing on
their own equipment moving computer
terminals activated despite no digital
trace of approved foundation login
credentials we must say we're a little
insulted by how much you've
underestimated us here we know the files
you've accessed we know that you're
aware of some of the monstrosities the
foundation deals with ghosts deadly
viruses reality warpers some creatures
that can shapeshift or become invisible
deadly memes for goodness sake did you
really think our personnel would see the
signs of your meddling and think it was
probably nothing that's a rather
dangerous oversight on your part
assumption number two you're attracted
to information about yourself don't try
to deny this one scp-3393
the fact you're still watching this
video is proof of yourself obsession and
you've left your digital fingerprints
all over any other file that made the
mistake of mentioning you we have pages
upon pages of logs showing your long
record of unauthorized access and the
grand majority of the files you accessed
were about you like we said you're a
vain little creature that much is plain
to see this leads us nicely onto
assumption number three you seek out
this information about yourself in order
to make changes to it or even delete it
entirely if it displeases you we'll
admit this one we find the most
frustrating it's one thing to access
files without our permission quite
another to mess with our hard work we
get enough problems from technical
director rosen already without needing
to constantly pester him about improving
file security the file about you has
undergone a number of needless
modifications and deletions the
following was a personal favorite quote
object class euclid special containment
procedures don't worry i can handle this
description i wasn't supposed to happen
i wasn't supposed to exist at least not
like this but let me deal with it this
thing that i am is best kept away from
all of you don't try to analyze me or
test me or whatever i don't want any of
you to catch what i have just call me
self-containing and we'll be good end
quote we suppose you thought this one
was pretty funny right you're clearly an
intelligent creature who or whatever you
are but the clear arrogance on display
here doesn't suit you while you may
coast off of your anti-memetic
properties it is important to remember
that you aren't untouchable speaking of
which assumption number four your
anti-memetic properties can be
transferred we found this to be a
particular interesting wrinkle in your
story we know you've got a sense of
humor so you'll have to appreciate the
irony in your attempts to alter or
destroy information about yourself
telling us more about you than we ever
knew before initially when other files
were reported missing we thought you
must have been deleting them out of
spite however upon further examination
we found that the files were still very
much there and you were the last user to
access them this is perhaps the most
dangerous thing about you and we don't
even know if you knew it until now your
anti-memetic properties have a tendency
to rub off and affect the things you
interact with with a power like that you
could compromise the whole database and
obviously we can't allow that to happen
assumption number
five you have a strong resistance to
memetic agents much to our frustration
we know that they can affect you of
course but your tolerance is far higher
than that of the average human being we
needed to load this video with some of
our very best just to make sure it would
actually work your memetic resistance
has even foiled certain prior
containment attempts so you've really
been making us earn our keep scp-3393
assumption number six you are confined
to site-31
this is another inconvenient truth for
you isn't it first we need to figure out
your corporeal being existing out here
in space-time with the rest of us and
then we figure out exactly which space
and time you're occupying can you feel
the net tightening around you 3393 of
course we don't want you to be nervous
just sit tight and enjoy the video
you're a very clever anomaly after all
far too clever to be contained by the
likes of us you've been performing your
operations right under the noses of
site-31's most talented personnel all
the phenomenon we've been attributing to
you from the open doors to the tampered
computer terminals have occurred
exclusively in site-31 and while we may
not be able to track down your account
and strip it of its phony clearances
did you know we can log which computer
terminals unauthorized access to our
files comes from that's just basic cyber
security and we don't need to tell you
that all of your unauthorized accesses
have been logged to site 31 terminals
very sloppy 3393 or should we call you
dr mackey forgive us if that isn't your
name we hate to jump to conclusions here
at the foundation but we couldn't help
but notice that your anomalous activity
began shortly after a researcher named
dr mackie disappeared from site 31.
interestingly much like you dr mackey
isn't remembered by anyone else on the
site we only know dr mackey worked here
from records we discovered not too long
ago we know that dr mackey was
conducting experiments here though data
on the particulars of those experiments
have been destroyed by you we presume we
also presume that you were most likely
either dr mackie or the product of one
of dr mackie's experiments we've made a
few attempts to nab you already but
you've always slipped through the cracks
like the sweep of side 31 where we sent
in mtf 8-10
our team that specializes in combating
visual cognito hazards those guys are
tough cookies and they're damn good at
their job so it is a mystery how you
evaded them our current best guess is
that you were hiding in some
undocumented location within the site
our attempts at memetic incapacitation
were equally unsuccessful as we
mentioned before it's clear that you
have a greater resilience to memetic
agents than any of your non-anomalous
counterparts we estimate that even a
kill agent would probably do little more
than weaken you that is impressive we'll
give you that our estimation for why
you've been able to so handedly thwart
our attempts at containing you is that
your access to the system has also given
you access to all of our plans you know
exactly what's going on before we even
execute the attempt giving you time to
think up and execute an effective
counter measure but we here at the
foundation believe that knowledge is
power
scp-3393 and we have more than enough to
finally contain you don't panic it's
already essentially over but we'll do
you the courtesy of explaining how we
got you in the end welcome to operation
bait the hook we know you're within
site31 and we know you're attracted to
information about yourself so we limited
the scope of where this handy little
video could be viewed to five terminals
in the site we put measures in place to
notify us whenever the file was accessed
and from which terminal at which point
mtf 8-10 would be dispatched to seal off
all available exits and quarantine the
room around the terminal a process that
would only take several minutes just
enough time for a vain little creature
to watch a video about itself as it's
forever entombed within the telltale
terminal that finally gave it away you
wouldn't be brought into a containment
chamber so we simply brought the
containment chamber to you as the
network connections for this particular
terminal are shut off we can safely say
you won't be causing us problems anymore
you're a very clever anomaly
scp-3393 just not quite as clever as us
now go check out scp-055
anti-meme unknown and
scp-3999 i'm at the center of everything
that happens to me for more mind-bending
anomalies from scp explained